We believe that if love is a chemical reaction,...
...chemistry has a good chance to make the world a more harmonious place.
Chemistry creates good relationships among the elements.
It finds secret formulas to unite, rather than separate things.
It works and then experiment after experiment.
Bandages end up loving the water.
Wheat can survive pests.
Families are less afraid of energy bills.
And even cars and city centers get along better.
Chemistry ultimately creates good relationships between people...
...and whatever they need in their lives.
That's why we don't just make chemicals,...
...we create chemistry.
BASF. The Chemical Company.